games that focus on close quarters
fighting can provide some of the most
nail-biting experiences in video games
at that range you have to think fast and
react faster
let's take a look at 8 games or levels
that nailed some really great aspects of
close quarters battles hit that like
button sub to the channel if you want
more and hey we're gonna find something
for everyone
ready or not is a team-based tactical
shooter that requires precision
coordination and planning fair warning
though this game is very mature themed
beyond just the shooting mechanics so do
your own research and decide if that's
what you're looking for right now there
are a lot of really fantastic systems at
play in this game that fans of older
swat titles will gravitate to so what
does it do well let's start off with
breaching door breaching is super
satisfying with multiple ways to do it
you can peak doors quietly kick them
down blow hinges with shotguns or go all
out with a breaching charge it just does
not get old team comms is great with
your ai teammates even if you're not
playing with friends you can easily
split your team into two groups queue up
a series of commands and then all attack
at once from two different directions
the single player command system is
pretty clever and easy to learn it seems
to remember what commands you're using a
lot and places them on a quick key
communication is context sensitive and
despite there being a lot of things you
can ask your squad to do it was
generally impressive how that never got
in your way your ai squad chatter is a
bit cringe but it gets the job done and
it reminds me a lot of squad chatter
from socom us navy seals back on the ps2
developer void interactive has said they
are working to improve dialogue in the
game readier nod also gets rid of a lot
of the guardrails that you didn't really
know existed in other shooters which is
pretty apparent the first time you get
shot through glass that you couldn't see
through because of the glare of the sun
or you're inside a building and you get
shot at from the outside you know you
never really feel safe and ready or not
which i love because movies and tv shows
and they almost always get this part of
close quarter battles wrong when someone
enters a room and screams clear the room
doesn't magically stay clear forever
clear just means clear for that second
and no promises after that in ready or
not enemies might run back into a room
you just cleared because you never know
you have to do things like wedge doors
shut behind you as you go or have your
team carefully cover where you've just
been another great aspect of swat style
games is that you're not trying to drop
everyone in sight you're tasked with
separating people who want to fight you
from people who want to give up or that
might need rescuing in which case you
secure them and move on you're not
exactly you know nice about it but
whatever it is what it is calm down
listen man i just want it to be over
man this one's a good one modern warfare
2 is coming out on november 10th and we
were able to see some of it ahead of
time so you'll be happy to know that
there are plenty of close quarter
battles
but it owes all of this to one of the
best levels in recent memory which is
the clean house mission from cod modern
warfare 2019. unlike any other call of
duty level this one sported only 11
enemies 11 enemies in a call of duty
level and you know it had a mix of heart
stopping shoot don't shoot no wait do
shoot and feel terrible about its
scenarios this level took place at night
and saw your team get plugged through
doors had you enter rooms with crying
babies hoping the high hell that the mom
in that room wasn't up for a fight and
generally made you feel extremely scared
to do the wrong thing it also begged for
repeated playthroughs to get that
perfect run players who killed all 11
baddies using only 11 bullets earned the
coveted golden path achievement it's one
of the most sweaty call of duty levels
and i mean that as a compliment
[Music]
right deep breath let's have some fun
and get away from the milsim for a
second to talk about a close quarters
fighting game that makes you feel about
as close to neo from the matrix as it
gets super hot places you in all kinds
of scenarios where you should be dead in
a second except time only moves when you
move so you have plenty of opportunities
to plan out big brain plays what this
game does so well is allow you the space
and time to do all the thinking before
acting on it the more you play the
faster and smarter you get making super
hot almost like a brain trainer but for
close quarters combat by the end you
will have sliced bullets with a sword
defeated an elevator full of enemies at
point-blank range like captain america
use the bottle to win a gunfight and
generally made yourself feel like a
certified genius super hot even has a vr
version that makes it even better
now when close quarters battle takes
place in larger urban areas there's a
lot more that can happen both inside and
outside of buildings
insurgency sandstorm has a lot of take
and hold objectives that throw you into
some intense fights the game also has
some of the most wicked sound design in
the industry and you'd be amazed how
much that affects you while you're
playing hearing enemies shout from
inside a building you're occupying is
genuinely terrifying
you'll see your pals get ganked with
crowbars blown up by bombers and taken
down instantly without top tier reflexes
it's probably one of the best made non
aaa shooters in a while
their recent update added a new much
more close quarters prison map and in
addition to that you absolutely can kick
doors just make sure you have a good
sense of what's on the other side
[Music]
back to a wild card pick hot dogs
horseshoes and hand grenades may have
you fighting some massive wieners
but the game also sports some of the
most realistic guns in all of vr not
even joking what h3 vr does so well is
what a lot of other vr titles do but
better and that's forcing you to grapple
with weapons as the complex mechanical
devices that they are or you totally
fail to especially under pressure and
even more unique is the ability to pull
off one-handed gun manipulation like
racking a slide against objects
something people who train for real cqb
learn in case one arm gets injured
that granular detail alone extends to
other situations like running low on
ammo and having to load a single bullet
into a magazine h3vr also has extensive
door breaching mechanics some of them
still in development which are well
beyond what you'd expect from a game
like this another advantage of this game
is it's pretty kid safe if you are
worried about playing shooters around
younger folks now okay my kids did have
a lot of questions about hot dogs though
and full disclosure h3vr is more of a
series of smaller games many of them
still in the work so don't expect a
super polished experience
but if you're after a safer vr choice
try titles like pavlov onward
contractors or firewall zero hour
firewall being for those of you with the
psvr
now vr is expensive so next let's look
at some budget picks that are a bit more
affordable zero hour not to be confused
with firewall zero hour for playstation
is around 12 bucks and is a great
starting point on steam if you want to
see if you have the patience for more
slow paced tactical shooters now it's
nothing fancy but it has a lot of the
basics like weapon customization
repelling on the sides of buildings
stacking up on doors and communication
like shoulder tapping your buddy to let
them know when to move in quietly the
enemies you fight are clever and can do
things like flank you take hostages hide
under beds and generally be
unpredictable these are features more
expensive games like ready or not are
still working on but like ready or not
you also lose points if you accidentally
drop enemies while they're trying to
surrender zero hour maps are smaller and
they focus almost entirely on building
interiors with some randomized aspects
think more of the way a game like payday
2 handled it with doors or room elements
moving around to keep you from knowing
exactly what to expect during each run
as a budget game you may encounter some
jank though if you want to spend a bit
more for an entry level tactical game
you can also drop 30 bucks for ground
branch which zero hour gets compared to
a lot and is a bit more polished ground
branch has a way more extensive
customization system more player stances
and ready positions a weightier feel and
better sound design
enemies in ground branch aren't really
anything special but they get the job
done ground branch also focuses on
larger maps with more open areas
now that we're looking for games for
anyone here's one you don't even need
twitch skills to enjoy because it's
turn-based strategy game even more
unique than that of all the games we've
talked about so far none of them have
perma-death but the x-com series does
if you screw up your favorite operator
is dead forever so no pressure that's
why the x-com series delivers one of the
most intense close quarters tactical
experiences an alien invested future can
offer now you might have already known
that but what some people might not have
discovered is that by using xcom's
destructible environments you can
totally ignore doors and breach into
rooms through walls which is something
modern special forces units have learned
to do in urban combat to stay out of
what's known as the fatal funnel that's
where teams can get channeled through a
single doorway and destroyed there are
tons of ways to do this including
grenades power fists and heavy weapons
later in the series xcom chimera squad
builds on the door kicking idea even
further with units initiating each fight
in a dedicated breach mode you'll have
honest-to-goodness classic cqb what's
stacking up tossing flashbangs and all
you can also pursue non-lethal means to
make arrests like the certified earth
cops you are
now since we're talking about ripping
open walls rainbow six siege is the only
other cqb game on this list that has
destructible environments
of all the games on the list siege is
your go-to for multiplayer especially
with its now seven years of updates
tuning and content if somehow you
haven't played this game yet give it a
try as tactical games go it's pretty
fast for a military inspired shooter and
casual rounds usually devolve into team
deathmatch style play rather than more
tactical playing of objectives with
headshots always being king
successful
so this is for folks who are a bit more
into run and gun shooters maybe even
counter striker valorant and who want to
mess around with cool gadgets but are
not looking for a hardcore slow moving
game that being said even though rounds
are fast a full ranked match between two
teams can still last 15 to 30 minutes
maybe longer for pick and ban matches
all right y'all this list was really
hard to pare down and we left quite a
few titles off i'm getting back an
escape from tarkov for example now if
you want a part 2 hit us with your
favorite cqb game that did something
clever or fun with close quarter battles
thanks for watching and remember i don't
always flashbang but when i do
i usually flashbang myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you